I'm Brian Kilmeade I'm Kennedy I'm Sean
Duffy and this is the Fox News Rundown
Friday February 17 2023 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal they say the air is clear and
the village well water is safe but Ohio
residents who live near where a Train
derailed and where toxic chemicals were
burned off are skeptical if you see
black smoke that's incomplete combustion
so some of this stuff was going into the
air not totally burned and we don't know
what that cloud contained I'm Chris
Foster Nikki Haley's running for
president saying mostly it's time for
generational change she's not the only
Republican younger than Joe Biden or
Donald Trump you can't run for the GOP
nomination and and not say why you're
the one of the GOP field who is the best
to take on whoever the Democrats have to
offer so she's gonna have to start
getting into policy and some tougher
questions about Trump we're speaking
with Fox News Sunday host Shannon bream
and I'm Tammy Bruce I've got the final
word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
residents who live in and around East
Palestine Ohio remain worried about the
effects of chemicals burned off in their
Town following a train derailment the
Norfolk Southern Train derailed February
3rd officials removed and burned off the
dangerous Vinyl chloride chemical
February 6 fearing if they did not the
chemicals might explode but the burn off
send up a giant plume of black smoke in
residents like Lisa Marie sopko could
feel it we feel you know our eyes
burning and you know we could feel like
our skin our Exposed Skin kind of
burning and so it definitely it was
terrifying Governor Mike dewine said
Wednesday air monitoring Village well
water testing show the area is safe they
told people though to hold off on
drinking from private wells until
testing was done on those but residents
remain suspicious Jenna gianos who lives
outside the previously evacuated area
started a Facebook group to help and she
started to see people who were told they
could return home not wanting to go home
anymore we have chickens foxes fish cats
like dying they were all near
um like near the area but not
necessarily in the evacuated area we've
had a lot of parts of the community come
together to help get some of those
larger animals outside like outside of
the area but I don't think anybody knows
what's far enough away that is on the
minds of many who are in and around the
evacuation Zone should they stay or
leave again Thursday was the worst day
yet
um just the first time I've ever smelled
it in my house Russell Murphy lives in
East Palestine Ohio and spoke to us
Thursday we have a wind change it's
coming it's coming straight North and
coming right up the road in front of us
up by Road and you can smell it in the
house it's the first time for that we
had some folks that were very kind to
bring us 500 gallons of water for the
horses that was uh they were from Erie
PA that they come down and brought water
so I was sticking around the house and
uh as far as the odor and the headache
it's almost like as soon as you put a
cough drop in your mouth you get that
Rush of that Menthol it makes your your
tongue tingly it um your gums are tingly
below your teeth behind your lips it's
um that there was so much chemical and
there still is you know and I think it's
getting worse I I don't think it's
getting any better
does that make you want to leave again
you sounds like you said you did leave
do you want to leave again
today is very odd today
has been an eye-opener yeah I I don't
know what to do and uh what's it gonna
do long term you know what kind of
environmental effects is this gonna this
this is horrible Russell uh just really
quickly what's your feeling right now
you're saying you're feeling a little
bit better that there seems to be some
sort of official response here at least
to the the testing of the water do you
feel like the response has been
sufficient do you feel like it was
lagging for a while and now people are
getting on top of it and what's your
sense of from the from your local
officials all the way up to the feds
I would say locally it's a town of 4 700
people
um and nor most towns of that size that
we're just not equipped for something
like this I mean you could take you take
a horror novel rip a chapter out of it
throw it on the Main Street East
Palestine and we're reading it and
living it because I think a lot of
people are just they're scared as hell
and as far as the chain of command goes
up
um Bill Johnson was at the Town Hall the
our Ohio Congressman you know he you
know he was quick to hand out his card
um you know the the dcnr the EPA the
Board of Health
um the Village of East Palestine yeah
they were there but it there was no
Direction you got there
um but Norfolk Southern was nowhere to
be found they elected not to come I
think they Ambush us you know they they
could they didn't even zoom in on a big
screen TV they said they were scared for
their safety and they they took their
toys and left and um they're the the
Goliath that um that made the mess and
then for them to have the daughter not
to show up you know it was just
unbelievable now as for what caused this
particular wreck the NTSB says
surveillance video from a residence
showed a wheel bearing in the final
stage of overheat failure on the train
just before it derailed some employees
of Norfolk Southern are questioning the
weight distribution of the train and the
length Governor dewine said this train
wasn't categorized as even having
hazardous materials on board he said he
wants Congress to look into that now
there's a conversation though about a
rule the Trump Administration repealed
that was going to require new braking
systems on trains Transportation
secretary Pete butterjudge who had not
spoken about the Ohio derailment said
Thursday he is constrained by legal
issues when it comes to this new break
rule the Trump Administration repealed
in all my 39 years doing the studies and
teaching and telling my guys about stuff
and teach the talk I've never come
across an incident where they actually
blew up rail cars and dumped the
chemicals into a pit to burn them off
still caggiano is a hazardous materials
specialist and former battalion chief
with the Youngstown Ohio fire department
to began with your adopting vinyl
chlorides and butyl acrylates into the
the waters there and when you decided to
burn it off the vinyl chlorides turned
into hydrogen chloride and phosgene now
phosgene was a World War One CG agent
that they used it was a choking age of
the Germans used you basically choke on
your own body fluids terrible way to go
but not before you have the coughing the
tearing of the eyes the you know the
rash of the skin from the acids you know
it all it's just horrible way to die and
hydrogen chloride is not much different
my concerns when they detonated the
whole thing other than being surprised
was that that back cloud in the fire
service if you see black smoke that's
incomplete combustion so some of this
stuff was going into the air not totally
burned and we don't know what that cloud
contained and you know my biggest fears
are dioxins furons that may have been
you know caused from the the incomplete
combustions and I'm looking at it and
saying you know my goodness basically
nuke the city and the reason why we did
this I think was to expedite the
remediation of the problem and to get
the rail lights open again well what
about the the idea that you know this
was the only option other than a
possible explosion I assume this is
better to have burned it off than to
have had an explosion but were those
really the only two options it sounds
like you're you said you're surprised
you said you've never seen any uh
response quite like this to deal with a
hazardous chemical situation so do you
feel like there were more options
I personally do yes
um for the first do engine companies
that were there did what they were
supposed to from what I've been told
they put unmonitored Master streams on
these tankers to cool them down and
Norfolk Southern told them to pull them
off because it wasn't going to have any
effect on
subsequently after they did that one of
the tankers started to heat up which
makes me kind of Wonder and to me it
just seemed to be a way to hurry up and
expedite getting rid of the product and
you know you think about it if they put
the fire out if it didn't Levy now they
have all these tanker cars of
unmarketable product that have to be
offloaded as Hazmat and disposed of as
Hazmat and Hazmat is very expensive to
dispose of this way it all got disposed
of in a cloud that got spread out over
God knows how how far so the governor
says this train wasn't labeled as having
hazardous materials on board given your
experience it sounds like there was a
relaxing of the rules or a changing of
the rules that I think governor dewine
was saying that because there were a
certain number of cars that had
hazardous materials in them and it
wasn't you know that many compared to
the rest of the train that that's why I
didn't get the label does that sound odd
to you you've been doing this a long
time and would you have assumed that at
least those cars should have been
labeled I mean he's saying we just the
state had no clue what he's referring to
is the consists the consist wasn't
directly available and I I find that
highly unusual because if you're
acquiring the local First Responders to
mitigate this they have the right and
Sarah title three gives them the right
to know what the heck they're dealing
with and you know I I find that
extremely Arcane that you would ask
somebody to mitigate something and
you're not giving them full disclosure
as to what the products are that they're
dealing with you know there should have
been safety data sheets attached to the
consist that spelled out the dangers of
these chemicals and gave you the names
of them I just find that just totally
you know anti-productive but it doesn't
surprise me because these problems with
the Rail lines and the safety they go
back probably to you know the Clinton
administration
and it's been infrastructure issues you
know aging Rail lines aging rail cars
you've got a braking system on these
cars it was developed after the Civil
War there are more technologically
advanced braking systems that prevent
cars from running into each other the
electronic brakes actually the executive
order to require the railroads to do
that was signed in under Obama and
subsequently under the Trump
administration because they felt it
wasn't cost effective was signed out
so you know cost effective ask the
people of uh you know East Palestine how
cost effective that is yeah it's very
costly what would you then tell because
secretary Transportation secretary Buda
judges come out and said well you know
we're limited by the law because the
Trump Administration repealed this new
braking system that was supposed to take
effect
um and he's saying you know we're
restricted in moving forward so what
would you tell then Congress or the
transportation secretary now under this
Administration what they should be doing
then if this is such a crucial issue and
these newer breaks should be on these
trains I would tell both sides of the
aisles this isn't a red issue or a blue
issue this is a people issue and when
you're dealing with people's lives you
have a great trust as an elected
official to make sure what's going down
the lines safe the people are safe and
if a problem happens there is measures
to help take care of it what you're
seeing in East Palestine is just a total
breakdown of you know the government's
ability to regulate the transportation
of these chemicals they have become you
know almost Owen and obligent to like
Norfolk Southern and these other rail
companies you know those people don't
care all they care about was getting
their darn cars back on the tracks you
don't send people home and say if you
want your house tested it's we'll be
there testing your house but within
minutes of doing that the trains were
running again in in East Palestine I
mean that's just crazy you had another
concern about that right with the
contaminated soil being put back onto
the area and so the is that a concern of
yours too as a Hazmat specialist that
the idea of these trains going through
and disturbing the soil it's full of
this contamination well not only that
they're disturbing the soil but it
random so guess what so guess what the
vinyl chloride did in that soil it
leached down into the ground
and people have wells out there you're
potentially contaminating well fields
and and it just seems like the whole
response through this it was a backup
and a backup and a backup and I don't
think they told the people the truth
from the get-go and I can only reinforce
that this cannot be allowed to continue
to happen East Palestine could be your
town could be My Town could be anybody's
town and people elect officials to
protect them they're not getting
protected by allowing these raila
industries to deregulate themselves and
get away with this stuff and these rules
have to be strengthened you have to
approve the infrastructure you have to
hold these people's feet to the fire
they're making billions of dollars and
you see very little investment back into
you know their infrastructures
thank you so much for joining us thank
you have a nice day
[Music]
this is Tammy Bruce with your Fox News
commentary coming up
former president Trump has company in
the Republican presidential race
a strong America
not America I am running for president
of the United States
former South Carolina Governor Nikki
Haley made her announcement this week in
Charleston she served as United Nations
Ambassador during the first two years of
the Trump Administration Dr Sean Hannity
asked if there are any issues where she
splits with the former president where
do you see if you see policy differences
beyond what you mentioned which are
generational differences what what
specific policy areas would you would
you say part with Donald Trump
I am saying is
is always I'm kicking forward Joe Biden
is the president he's the one I'm
running against for now she has some of
the spotlight to herself she brings us a
lot of energy of course she would be
history making and she's the first one
willing to dip her toe in against the
former president Donald Trump who she
had said she wouldn't run if he did
Shannon bream's the host of Fox News
Sunday she's got a lot of interesting
buzz but a lot of the deeper dive on her
is okay what is her domestic policy what
is she going to do that will
differentiate her from the rest of the
field where does she break with the
former president on policy after having
served in his administration she hasn't
really gotten into a lot of those
questions to answer those just yet she
will continue to say this is about
taking out Joe Biden as president of
this country I'm the one who can win
against him if he runs for reelection
but he doesn't really want to talk about
the GOP field and she's going to have to
because I think that primary we all know
is going to get very heated yeah I mean
I guess she just figures Ed why not get
out there and have a short amount of
time at least where people are only
talking about me as far as Challengers
to Donald Trump now like everybody else
she's talking around Trump at most no
one's saying his name like it's cursed
or something and nobody wants to be the
first to go right at him you don't want
to draw his wrath you don't want to draw
his supporters wrath it may have to be a
safety and numbers thing where once more
people are in they just all try to Pig
pile I mean even then you can take off
his supporters and just make it more
popular but I don't know how else you do
it you got to go through them at some
point yeah I think you're absolutely
right and she does have kind of this
open field at this point because there
aren't other GOP folks and we know
there's a lot of
chatter about you know Tim Scott Mike
Pompeo Mike Pence and many others out
there but for now she's got the
spotlight to herself you know the former
president announced last fall and a lot
of folks thought it was so early it
would get kind of lost in the holidays
he hasn't been doing a ton of events
he's starting to so yeah she's got a
little bit of time where she can have
the microphone and have this
conversation but I think she's gonna
have to answer those tough questions
about what makes her different what you
can't run for the GOP nomination and and
not say why you're the one of the GOP
field who is the best to take on whoever
the Democrats have to offer so she's
gonna have to start getting into policy
and some tougher questions about Trump
yeah I mean she can talk about how we
need generational change but then so can
Tim Scott so can Glenn youngin so can
Rhonda Santos yeah yeah so um something
she's without another way she's talking
about Trump without talking about Trump
and obviously talking about President
Biden she's calling for a competency
test however that whatever that means
for politicians over 75
um you know she's clearly just trying to
say she's trying to forward her
generational change thing is that is it
valid or just discriminatory or what I
think it does Spotlight that if these
two candidates from 2020 rematch
President Biden and former president
Trump you know it was her one way of
taking a little bit of a swipe at Trump
because she did say you know we have
these guys running who are 80 like is
that really what's the best thing for
the country well that's not just buying
that does include Trump as well so it is
kind of the tiniest little glimmer of
taking a bit of a swipe at him but it
does change that conversation you know I
think back about President Reagan saying
okay let's talk about the elephant in
the room I'm not going to hold your
agent and experience your youth against
you so you know a smart older candidate
is going to be able to turn that to
their to their advantage but it is
something that distinguishes her from
the two we think are in for 24. yeah
speaking of older now no longer a
candidate Dianne Feinstein has announced
her retirement
um after I think like 30 years in the
Senate it's going to be
um now that's a lot of big name
Democrats with all about the same
politics who are going to be calling for
that seat how do they differentiate
themselves
that's a great question too I was just
out in California for a couple of days
and there is some chatter about this
race I mean when you've had the same
senator for decades there are questions
because listen everybody who has ever
thought of running for the Senate that's
a Democrat out there is going to get
into this thing because it's so rare
that a seat opens up it's very powerful
and can in California keep you in the
senate for decades so you know the atom
shifts and the others who are talking
about getting in
um gosh I think it's going to be a
little bit like the Republican primary
we saw in 2016 where you have like 17
people on stage trying to figure out
who's going to be the best bet here but
this is their time to shoot their shot
it's the time that seat is going to be
open and I just expect it's going to be
a very crowded field and I would imagine
it's going to pull progressively left I
don't think a moderate candidate is
going to make it through the primary
yeah just back to the presidential stuff
for a minute if it's Trump Biden again
do you see a lane for an independent to
have a big impact maybe not win but draw
I mean Ross Perot got I think 19 back in
the day
um I don't know who that could possibly
be or who it might siphon votes off from
but if enough people are sick of the
guys that are there and don't want to
see a sequel to that maybe somebody can
Bubble Up yeah it's a real danger for
both the candidates if those two get
back in because the polling shows us
repeatedly especially in recent weeks
that people do not want this rematch so
you know I think what the Republicans
are more worried about is that somehow
everybody coalesces behind someone other
than president Trump there's a different
GOP nominee and he decides to be the
third party candidate I mean there are
real concerns and kind of consternations
about that because you know you heard
him a week or two ago with Hugh Hewitt
said that he wouldn't pledge that he
would support whoever the GOP nominee is
if it's not him yeah uh and that's got
to be something that Rhonda Santos or
whoever it is
um probably has to worry about in the
back of their mind we keep saying Rhonda
Santos because he's you know sort of
been anointed by people in our industry
and whatever is is the guy but I mean
look in in 2016 Jeb Bush led the polls
at one point Ben Carson led the polls in
2012 a half a dozen people led the polls
Rick Santorum at one point led the polls
Scott Walker Scott Walker yeah so it's
very very early it is and you don't want
to Peak too soon I mean DeSantis just
got reelected
overwhelmingly in Florida he's got a lot
of love there and I think he knows for
him to win this race and immediately
pivot to the presidency listen everybody
expects or thinks that it will probably
happen but he's aware of the Optics of
that also let some of these other people
get in and burn some of their Capital he
does not feel in any way according to
folks close to him the pressure to get
in anytime soon let some other people
get in there mix it up see how Trump
does you know we're also waiting for the
former president on a number of legal
fronts as well we're going to get this
special grand jury released from Georgia
after allegations that he or his allies
tried to tamper with election results
there in 2020 I mean he there are some
other you know doj investigation there
are some serious legal issues that that
may face the former president so I think
desantisim is among those saying let's
hang back let's see what happens let's
see who else gets in
um I think he knows when he gets in it
will make all of the headlines and he
doesn't feel like he needs to rush uh
moving on to social media and talking
Congress about that Missouri Republican
senator Josh Hawley
um says hey maybe it's time to set a
legal age for social media 16 years old
to protect kids mental health or studies
saying it's not good for them at this
point it's something that kids have just
grown up with uh kids who are 16 15
whatever
um I mean I guess the case would have to
be to come at it like a public health
concern yeah and the thing is he said
you know parents need our help and I've
talked to you know parents with
teenagers and kids who are on the stuff
all day every day and they're like it
would be kind of nice for us to be able
to point to the law and say like sorry
it's illegal for you to have Tick Tock
or it's illegal for you to have Twitter
and so you know I just can't let you do
it and I think the onus would be put on
the companies to somehow have some kind
of screening too it would be on them to
make sure that they didn't have people
under 16 on their platforms now
advertisers love having those kids there
they know how addicted people get and I
don't know that the social media
companies are going to be excited or say
like yeah the biggest part of our
segment of customers we're going to kick
them off these apps I think it's gonna
be really hard to get them to go along
with it and they have very strong
lobbyists and and a lot of poll in
Washington so I don't know if it goes
anywhere um but their parents are out
there say like yeah I'd love to point
the finger at someone else as the reason
my kids can't have these apps yeah if
that actually gets traction and Congress
it will obviously be a knock down drag
out or knock knock down drag out fight
um from the Seattle companies yeah
against that
um East Palestine Ohio a lot of mistrust
there about this train derailment and
the chemical spill and the chemical burn
off a couple weeks ago um if it's so
safe they say why do so many of us feel
like crap coughs and rashes and
headaches I'm not sure what's next here
I know I I think gosh this kind of for a
lot of people who weren't local went
under the radar for a few days where the
local vehicles have been screaming and
saying our animals are dying our pets
are dying we don't feel good this thing
was heard and seen and smelled miles and
miles away they've been trying to raise
the red flag and so now that we're many
many days into this and people feeling
like they weren't getting the full
information and this this is not being
fully and seriously taken it's only
gonna get worse because not meaning the
physical I don't understand I have no
idea how that's going to play out it
doesn't look great but questions about
why there wasn't faster action why there
wasn't more transparency why there
weren't more Federal assets on the
ground what happened with the train why
were these decisions made now look the
EPA and state officials are saying we've
measured everything we've measured the
air we've measured the municipal water
and it's fine
um nevertheless people are reporting
these symptoms
um I so I just don't know what else you
can tell people other than look maybe
unless you're testing for the wrong
thing or you don't trust the test them
so cells and some people are saying look
I I want to move out of here I'm afraid
of living in Chernobyl we think about
how many things have happened that until
they got Beyond a crisis Point like the
Flint water situation and others where
people feel like they were fighting for
answers fighting for help and it took a
long time until it became a national
Scandal and people got involved
um you know all the polling shows us
that unfortunately people are
questioning the Integrity of our
institutions they've become very
skeptical of the government and these
federal agencies and so when they see
evidence they think you know in their
own backyards they've got their own kids
to worry about their own family story
about their very reticent many of them
to believe that they're getting the full
story so I think that this thing is only
going to Bubble Up into an even bigger
Scandal about why people didn't have
more information have it you know more
quickly more transparently and we may
not know exactly how bad this thing is
until we're five ten years down the road
yeah and maybe in the shorter term more
talk about infrastructure and more talk
about it labor rules like there was talk
that a lot of those people on those
crews are are fatigued and the trains
sped through too fast and that people
have been worried about this kind of
thing for a long time Shannon bream host
of Fox News Sunday as always thank you
have a great weekend
[Music]
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
kindness the norm that's the theme today
for this year's random acts of kindness
day it was started in 1995 in Denver
Colorado by the non-profit random acts
of kindness Foundation being kind isn't
just a nice thing to do it's also good
for our physical and mental health
Studies have shown that performing acts
of generosity lower blood pressure among
other benefits small acts like holding
the door for a stranger petting an
animal or bringing coffee to a colleague
can have an effect as well researchers
say even witnessing acts of kindness has
been shown to increase well-being Tanya
J Powers Fox News
listen to the all-new Brett Bear podcast
featuring Common Ground in-depth talks
with lawmakers from opposite sides of
the aisle along with all your bread bear
favorites like his All-Star panel and
much more available now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for
your Fox News commentary Tammy Bruce
what's on your mind some Democrats want
to give federal workers an 8.7 pay raise
make no mistake we want everyone to do
well but it appears we have a government
that is picking those who will suffer
under the Democrats historic inflation
and those who will not federal workers
received a 4.6 percent raise from
President Biden in 2023 if passed this
legislation would provide the additional
raise in 2024. that's awfully nice of
them considering Democratic policy
caused the inflation that has crushed
real wages of ordinary Americans but for
Democrats the only people that matter
are the people in the government
bureaucracy the latest confession of not
giving a damn about ordinary Americans
arrives courtesy of Representative Jerry
Connolly the Democrat of Virginia and
Senator Brian Schatz the Democrat out of
Hawaii and their Federal adjustment of
income rates legislation allowing the
8.7 pay raise for 2 million federal
workers Americans who are not part of
the permanent bureaucracy will have to
continue to suffer under the worst
inflation in 40 years to single out
federal workers for Relief as everyone
else suffers confirms the growing
American unease that the federal
government has lost touch with
everything that matters but don't fret
we are told there are special reasons
why this pay raise is needed for federal
workers according to Connolly quote for
years now federal employees have risked
their health and safety working on the
front lines of this pandemic they were
subjected to the Trump administration's
cruel personal attacks unsafe work
environments pay freezes government
shutdowns sequestration cuts furloughs
and Mindless across the board hiring
freezes reported Fox News
oh so it's to soothe the emotional
injuries caused by Trump well okie dokie
then with that Connolly's rant confirms
that what the Democrats are doing to the
country has always been about revenge
for Trump not only do they continue to
persecute him they are punishing
Americans writ large for daring to think
for ourselves and rejecting the swamp in
2016. also raising eyebrows is the claim
that the raise is required because
federal workers suffered on the quote
front line during covet perhaps those
involved in health care but the GAO
confirms what we already knew all
federal agencies relied heavily on
telework some compromising as much as 80
percent of total work time we all
remember those on the front lines of
covid the cashiers and workers at
supermarkets those working at pharmacies
First Responders firefighters police
officers and EMTs among so many other
ordinary Americans doing their jobs
every day no matter what but they too
suffer because of a self-absorbed
permanent Washington bureaucracy and
policies which eat away at our
pocketbook quality of life and even hope
for a decent future for our families
keep in mind ordinary Americans have had
over four thousand dollars a year
disappear from their buying power as
real wages are crushed by Biden's
monster inflation Joe Biden's campaign
for the presidency was premised on
getting us back to normalcy for them it
appears normal is destroying the economy
facilitating an explosion of crime a
dissolved Southern border and a bumbling
foreign policy leading us into more
chaos and War we have a choice about
whether or not we accept this warped and
cancerous normal or if we will once
again reject their incompetence in 2024
which will be here faster than you think
we will have another chance to kick
these vandals to the curb
I'm Tammy Bruce this column can be read
in its entirety at amac.us and my show
at Fox Nation is called get Tammy Bruce
[Music]
the Fox News rundown and now stay up to
date by subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad-free on
Fox News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad-free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
hear the news now you can with instant
updates from Fox News for Amazon Alexa
just say Alexa play news from fox in Fox
News it's the latest when you need it on
demand from Fox News and Amazon Alexa